and Victor michalevsky winning his
second game of the tournament and we do
have him in the studio so welcome back
congratulations we actually didn't get a
chance to look at your game so we can
look at it together so let's go
um to your game and please tell us where
is your preparation what were you
expecting uh I expected Bishop before a
check this line but I didn't expect A5
already because he mostly played Bishop
D6 before
so that's what I prepared but A5 I
couldn't remember any series here so
Bishop G2 I just knew some ideas but
nothing concrete uh
so
yeah
Queen C2 yeah I assume it's all Siri but
well I think the good thing is for your
moves are so natural right yeah even if
you don't know Theory or pieces just
have their attention it's a typical
Catalan compensation for the phone
and B5 yeah but sometimes if you don't
really know you may end up on down and
so
around this okay so he so he hangs onto
the pond between is also very typical
all of this is very typical but then
I don't know if white I mean white has
compensation for sure but I don't know
if it's enough or anything
like for any advantage or
and before what do you think a lot about
allowing this past Pawn
it's also typical to allow before a b
takes A4 is another possible idea I
thought and then put a bishop on before
yes so I would have probably taken on S6
and then
yeah then probably just think
so before was played yeah
yeah
it looks a little scary to illow Knight
C3 but anyway I cannot stop it so
yeah it's important that Bishop takes E2
tactics won't work
um
Knight B3 and I'm protecting everything
like
yes
this should be good
yeah I saw it for a long time before
playing E3 looks like a very complicated
position I consider it Bishop E4 idea to
Provo G6 because if he exchanges the
Knight I thought it will be good for me
just going to exit
in the bed but he just plays G6
basically his idea is to play F6 at some
point yeah kick this now
[Music]
okay so you just want to provoke g6s too
yeah and then after F6 I want to take
Knight C6 so I didn't know maybe to
provoke G6 and then after F6 still
Knight exists
so you play three year and reports your
Center yeah and the two Pawn is not
hanging in some lines
so now I take take rookie 70 Brook seeds
and I have Bishop D7
and Rook takes C5 DTX C5 my Bishop is
protected but I wasn't sure even this
position he may have compensation like
Rook C5 dc5 Queen C5 Bishop E6 King h8
my lights were selling a little weak and
the Knight on C3 is pretty strong so ah
you have but you have uh you have a
tactic here I mean tactically you bring
it yeah yeah
yes and it's probably good okay so
instead he went through K7 stopping any
Bishop D7 Queen B3 so you did win your
Pawn back but at this yeah but this
position still looks fine I think Bishop
C his idea is to just play five foot at
some point so I can't get and he
wants to play five so I thought I need
to exchange the strong Knight on C3
uh so he really wants to have something
on City yeah Rook C1 runs into 92 of
course yeah
serok C2
ticks takes
yeah F5
yeah somehow I believe black should be
fine here so how did you evaluate this
position
probably about equal but
I'm not even sure who is playing for a
win in this position
because you have immediate Roxy one ah
computer shows it's better for black
right yeah it could be yeah so if you
want Rook C1
7 65 okay so if you take this part
you'll be quite happy oh you did take
this one yeah it's possible to defend
this right or maybe Rook C8 with Rook
City yeah then I go Queen B2 so yeah I
wasn't sure but this position so Rook C
they just say so they can take on A5 oh
you want to click on A5 maybe if it's
possible I don't know like Rook C1
Bishop F1 I wasn't sure about this oh
this looks very scary for you it looks a
little scary but I have a straight at
The Rook C5 Rook C5 Queen before okay he
should do something he doesn't have time
for E5 F4 stuff okay so I have to move
this screen yeah like in D6 and then
yeah I don't know if I can untangle
somehow
[Music]
it should be okay for me but it's still
very concrete because he has Rook C3
Queen B6 B3 ideas I cannot take the Rook
because of B2
so Queen B6 but then I thought maybe
we'll create a five
becoming some kind of a ponderance but
this looks very good for you already
yeah probably I can even play 687 rookie
Shades that's my suit yeah it's very
strong yeah
he played first queen B6 rookie five and
then rocks it I checked you first but
this check is is it helpful so he went
to A1 just to stop my to stop my idea of
a five five okay yeah he just said that
he missed Roxy's 385 I have this
intermediate move if he plays instead of
Rook C1 check high five it's very strong
and then I if take screen takes C3 in
the queen E5 Queen before I map upon oh
very nice and a nice structure yes
very nice but to oh sorry yes so yeah D5
I think yeah should be played and we
should pay for right two and you take
and
for me so here probably it's already
good for white
so D6
I assumed it should win and he was also
in the time travel it's impossible to
stop this one 26 no he can stop because
if Queen D5 Rook D1
so you want queen of seven with huge
threats it's a group D1 anyways
yeah and now you just checkmating uh
right
he said that he he could play Queen F6
in this position
I'm not sure how to press it here there
should be some way but over here here
and
yeah this one is actually kind of
dangerous too right yeah but I should
have something maybe four no I don't
know maybe you can bring this bishop
what is computer suggesting here H5 P3
Bishop F1
oh it actually says even if you yeah and
back probably yeah and then uh there is
still this big shirt well and yeah this
is very powerful yeah so problem still
winning
sorry so he went Rook D2 but then I mean
by force uh Queenie Bishop F5 indeed yes
you can do it very nice because Queen
did Queen G6 yeah look after King H3
doesn't change anything if Queen did
Queen g67 checkmate
wow very nice game well congratulations
so now you're in the lead with uh three
points no no I have two and a half I
lost yesterday oh yeah you lost
yesterday okay and who do you play
tomorrow I have no idea okay everyone
spoil it for you well thank you so much
for joining us congratulations on your
win thank you